what have you learned about life from
your father Robert F Kennedy first of
all I'll say this about my uncle because
you know I'm going to apply that
question to my uncle and my father my
uncle was asked when he first met Jackie
Bouvier who later became Jackie Kennedy
she was a reporter for a newspaper and
she was doing she she had a kind of
column where she'd do these these kind
of um
pithy interviews uh with with both
famous people and Men industry in
interviews
and she was interviewing him and she
asked them
um
what she thought what he believed as
best quality was is his strongest virtue
and she thought that he would say
courage because
he had been a war hero he had he was the
only uh president who and this one he
was Senator by the way
who received the purple heart and you
know he had a very kind of famous story
of him as a hero in World War II and
then he had come home and he'd written a
book on car on moral courage among
American politicians and won the
Pulitzer Prize
that book profiles and courage and uh
which was a series of incidents where
um American political leaders made
decisions to to embrace principle even
though their careers were at stake and
in most cases were destroyed by their
choice
she thought he was going to say courage
but he didn't he said curiosity
and
um I think you know looking back at his
life that the best that that was true
and that was the quality that allowed
him
to put himself in the shoes of his
adversaries and he always said that if
you if the only way that we're going to
have peace is if we're able to put
ourselves in the shoes or adversaries
understand their behavior and their
contact not context
and that's why he was able to
um you know during the uh he was able to
resist the intelligence apparatus in the
military
during the Bay of Pigs when they said
you've got to send in the Essex the
aircraft carrier and he said no even
though he'd only been in two months in
office he was able to stand up to them
because
of because he was able to put himself in
the shoes of both Castro and Khrushchev
and understand there's got to be another
solution to this and then during the
Cuban Missile Crisis
he was able to do it when the narrative
was okay Khrushchev acted
in a way as an aggressor to put missiles
in our hemisphere how dare he do that
and Jack and my father were able to say
well wait a minute he's doing that
because we put missiles in turkey and
Italy that were right on you know the
Turkish ones right on the Russian border
and they then made a secret deal with
dobrandon with ambassador to Brennan and
you know with Khrushchev
um to uh to remove the missiles in in
Turkey if he moved the Jupiter missiles
from Turkey if I'm
so long as Khrushchev removed them from
from
Cuba every there were 13 men on the
executive on the end what they call the
encount committee
which was the group of people who were
deciding you know what the action was
what what they were going to do to end
the Cuban muscle crisis and virtually I
and of those men 11 of them wanted to
invade and wanted to bomb and invade
and it was Jack and then later on my my
father and and Bob McNamara who were the
only people who were with him
but because he was able to see the world
from khrushchev's point of view of you
he believed that there was another
solution and then he also had the moral
courage so
um my father you know to get back to
your question
famously is that that moral courage is
the most important quality and it's more
it's more rare and courage on the
football field or courage in battle than
physical courage it's much more
difficult to come by but it's the most
important quality in a human being and
you think that kind of empathy that you
referred to that requires moral courage
it certainly
requires moral courage to
to act on it you know and particularly
you know in
you know any time that a nation is at
War there's kind of a momentum or an
inertia that says okay let's not look at
this from the other person's point of
view
and um that's the time we really need to
do that